you're watching swype coming up on this
week's show mind control computers and a
portable DNA lab the new inventions
being developed at UK universities meet
my new friend Marty a dancing 3d printed
robot he looks like a toy but he's got a
more serious side too and is this the
future of messaging a new way to express
yourself in our tech news roundup hello
and welcome to swipe this week were in
central London at the Royal Institution
their slogan is science lives here and
today they're really proving that
because inventors and engineers are
showing off some of the newest
technologies being developed in the UK
here's to with some of those
groundbreaking inventions so it's punch
nay oh very good controlling a computer
with the power of my mind this wearable
neuro technology allows me to play these
games without moving it could help
people who can't move because of
disabilities or injuries to communicate
the ID of the gman is to motivate people
while the tree and so even people that
we work with patients and so on we'll
get them to use these games as a means
to learn how to modulate their brain
activity and the people improve it
largely at interactivity and once
they've mastered it or got a level of
accuracy that's reliable then they can
move on to possibly answering questions
or doing some other things with
assistive technology other inventions on
show here include these fabric
electrodes which could change wearables
allowing technology to be woven into
your clothes they're a refined version
of the ones you may have seen used in
pain relief in a TENS machine for
example the old paper is very sticky and
so it's not comfortable to wear and it's
not washable so it's not suitable for
long-term use with mine so dry lectured
which is comfortable to wear now we
integrate into a piece of clothing so
it's easy to use and it's washboard
therefore it's a reusable and cost
effective and cheaper these inventions
have been made
UK universities and the inventors are
here working with the Royal Academy of
Engineering to meet investors some of
the products you probably won't want for
personal use but they could make a
difference to specific professions or
hobbies like this invention a DNA lab
that's been condensed into a laptop size
case each three or four bits of these
kits would be separate so they'd be kind
of like their entire entity and they can
really vary in size anything from
something that's relatively compact
maybe the size of this box to fitting
this entire table but then the other
advantage of the Benton lab is that it
costs 700 pounds so that's a huge
reduction but they're the best you could
get it for on the market at the moment
the similar kind of tech would be 4,500
these inventors are improving on their
designs all the time you'll be able to
see the updated bento lab and neuro
concise is new headset design in the
near future Stewart Duggan Sky News stay
with us here in the Royal Institution
I'll be meeting a 3d printed wiggling
robot coming right up after a round up
of some of these sweeps other tech news
sending a message just got way more
expressive a new apps launched that
interacts through personalized
animations acting out whatever you want
to say raw can also automatically
convert hashtagged words into avatar
actions and let you impersonate
celebrities and while we're on the
subject of communication take a look at
this gadget that apparently fits inside
your ear translating foreign languages
can you hear me fresh from a little hole
faucet the creators of pilots claim it's
the world's first smart earpiece which
translates between users speaking
different languages they're beginning
crowdfunding on IndieGoGo the clever
students at Stanford University have
come up with a flying robot that can
land on walls and ceilings the
quadcopter can stay perched in its
position filming video for hours until
its battery runs out the technology
could be used in earthquake and fire
rescue's or for things like cracking
actions on bridges and dams in Rwanda
drones are set to be used for carrying
blood and vaccines to transfusion
centers to make deliveries faster the
government there is working with
us-based robotics firm zipline to begin
the drone flights by August stick around
for our games review do makes a comeback
and it's not the only first person
shooter we've got in our sights now
remember that robot I mentioned earlier
come and meet Marty and his creator Alex
ear hello Alex hello now these Marty's
brothers or they all call Marty well
these ones are all called Marty cuz I'm
not very imaginative if you have your
own one at home you can call it whatever
you like and how is Marty different from
any other little robot that can shake
his legs like that well as you can see
that what makes him really special is
the way that his legs move and actually
use fewer motors than a normal robot
would and that makes him easier to
program and cheaper to build and who did
you design Marty for apart from myself I
designed him for my nieces and nephews
so I just finished my PhD in robotics
and when I was looking for a robot toy
to buy them I wanted something that was
a bit more of a real robot so I decided
to build one he's a children's toy he's
kind of a children's story he's also a
real robot so you could use him to teach
all the way up to university level even
ok so how can we make him move again
well we have here someone called scratch
which is a programming language that
kids can use it's really easy you just
click and drag these blocks and then so
you can see there it says walk and then
kick and then we're going ok so we're
going to make him walk kick and wiggle
yep Hey and so a child would have this
on their tablet or computer yeah exactly
so they're learning to program as well
as playing with a toy yep exactly i see
when i was a kid if if I had a toy
that's great I love playing with toys
but if I found out that it actually had
a dual purpose and it really was trying
to teach me it was an educational tool I
don't know whether I'd want to play with
anymore it's a tricky balance I mean
what we have to do is to make it
something that's fun like so minecraft
there's a way that you can use Pais in
the programming language to mess around
in Minecraft and it's still fun so we're
trying to the same thing where you can
use scratch or you can use Python to
play with the robot and even though you
may be learning a bit you're still also
thinking about football strategies or
other stuff so you don't mind too much
what about parents they must have to
know
how to program to be able to give this
to their children the nice thing about
it is that with these simple programming
languages it's just as easy for the
parents to get started as well so the
parents can learn about programming in
the evening if they want to and did your
niece and nephew like Marty they did so
Juliet my niece is really wanting one
and i need to make another one for her
you haven't given a one yet all right
well good luck and I hope she loves it
thank you
time for a bit of nostalgia now if you
remember the early 90s chances are you
played doom in fact it might have been
one of the first games you ever played
well it's had an update adam has
reviewed the monster shooter for us and
a few other new titles if it wasn't for
1993 we never would have had robin hood
men in tights but that being said it was
also the year a certain monster slaying
adventure called doom blew your grandma
socks off and 23 years later the
gloriously gruesome franchise is back
the concept is really simple slay bad
things escape with your limbs intact and
always always take a chainsaw to a
demonic party
now in Doom speed is your greatest ally
if you're someone who tends to beat
around the bushes and you know who you
are always think twice out your tactics
when tackling the nightmares on Mars
it's all like getting we are going fast
and always remember take a space case
full of ammo along for the ride the
multiplayer options are also a hoot as
as plenty to plow your way through such
as classic deathmatch and domination but
it's the intuitive doom snap map option
that allows you to create your own
levels of hellish chaos to share with
other players on the fly sublime new
graphics hideously delicious melee
attacks hordes of rank looking monsters
and so many outrageous weapons doom is
action incarnate we've been long overdue
a first-person shooter which takes a
step back from the brutal realism of the
genre and goes more down an animated
route adding a bit more creative flair
I've got you in my sights
overwatch is a beautifully crafted
online multiplayer which has been
compared to the likes of Team Fortress 2
and add to the well-polished heritage of
Blizzard Entertainment's repertoire
where overwatch really stands out for me
is in it's brilliant array of characters
each unique and playing an integral part
in the way that you shape your tactics
went out on the battlefield choosing one
of the multitude of offensive defensive
tank and support characters you'll be
able to change your tactics on a whim as
the match progresses to really even the
playing field it's also a really nice
touch at the end of a round you can vote
for your player of that match so even if
your team's a total bust at least you
can walk away with your head held high
if you haven't dreamt of living in a
sewer or fighting men in body stockings
then you haven't lived you shouldn't
underestimate the power of a good
old-fashioned hacking slasher especially
when you can play as the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Cowabunga just getting
started
mutants in Manhattan is the latest entry
into the series and you can expect all
the old guard back for another beating
the shredder bebop Rocksteady the Foot
Clan are all there to try and turn
Leonardo Michelangelo Donatello and
Raphael into turtle soup in this cell
shaded beta match
undoubtedly tying its release in with
the new out of the shadows movie mutants
in Manhattan maybe better place in a
classic arcade but I've no doubt that
the younger ninjas out there are going
to have an absolute blast with it well
that's it for this week take a look at
Sky News on mobile tablet catch-up
snapchat and sky cube all the latest
tech stories throughout with see you
again next time bye-bye